Thank you everyone. My name is Justin Shapiro, and I'm here representing Circle
Pharma. We are a biotech drug discovery company focused on
developing orally bioavailable macrocycles which can target and
disrupt intracellular protein-protein interactions.
Quick plugs for the plenary clinical session tomorrow and the new drugs on the
horizon session the day after. Please go check those out.
But in the meantime, I have a bit of a discovery story for you.
So, no one in this audience needs to be told that peptide therapeutics are having a
little bit of a moment. Specifically, the subset of macrocyclic
peptides have had a couple of really high-profile successes against
very challenging targets recently.
And this has highlighted the ability of this exciting modality to get the
kinds of pharmacokinetic parameters and manufacturability of small
molecules balanced with the kinds of potency and selectivity that you
can typically only get out of biologics.
But if we take a broad view of the field, some remaining obstacles emerge.
The space can be broadly divided along two axes, with the route of administration
shown along the top and the location of the molecular target shown along the
side.
For compounds with extracellular targets, many of them rely on a number of
charged residues to tightly interact with the protein of interest,
and therefore the development of a more neutral and potentially more orally
bioavailable analog with sufficient potency is simply going to be out of the
question.
If you begin to carve away charge, you can gain access to the interior of the cell,
but many compounds with intracellular targets still do not have intrinsic
oral bioavailability. They cannot cross the gut wall, and therefore they
must be administered via injection, putting them in the bottom left.
If you have exquisite potency for an extracellular target and you're not too
bogged down by charge, you can hope for oral dosing, as in the case of
Merck's PCSK9 inhibitors and the recently unveiled
IL-23 oral inhibitor.
Compounds in this upper right-hand box do not tend to have intrinsic oral
bioavailability,
but with the help of an enabling formulation, enough of them can get forced
past the gut wall that they can find and inhibit their extracellular target
without ever having to cross a membrane all by themselves.
There are macrocyclic peptides which both have intrinsic oral bioavailability
and are able to passively permeate a cell membrane to find and
inhibit their intracellular targets.
But case studies are few and far between, and importantly, they have largely
focused to date on targets which can be drugged via non-peptide
modalities such as RAS.
So Circle Pharma aims to populate this bottom right-hand box with new targets that
have novel mechanisms of action which are currently considered undruggable.
I think this audience is probably familiar with the cell cycle, but very briefly,
it is the process by which a cell grows, duplicates DNA, and divides
in two. And in a healthy cell, the orderly transition between the
phases of the cell cycle is a tightly regulated process controlled
by cyclin-dependent kinase phosphorylation events, and those are
regulated even further by their cognate cyclins.
The cyclin serves two key functions here.
The first is to cause a conformational shift in the CDK, which turns on its
catalytic activity,
and the second is to recruit regulatory peptides through protein-protein
interactions with a hotspot on the cyclin surface.
Once localized to the complex, the substrate can wrap itself around and the
business end can get phosphorylated, and then the downstream regulatory
cascade can proceed.
So in cancer cells, unmitigated progression through this cell cycle leads to
uncontrolled cell growth, and so strategies for inhibiting the cell cycle have
been of interest to the industry for decades, most clearly exemplified
by clinically approved CDK4/6 inhibitors targeting the kinase-active
site.
But that approach has drawbacks. High structural homology between kinase-active
sites can lead to off-target toxicity, and resistance development is a known
concern. So alternative strategies for modulating the cell
cycle are still highly attractive.
One way of going about this is by targeting the substrate recruitment site on the
surface of the cyclin.
Shown here is the RXL binding site of cyclin A, so called
because it recognizes a conserved sequence found across many cyclin
substrates.
And a member of our scientific advisory board, Bill Kaelin, was the first to
demonstrate the potential for synthetic lethality in specific
kinds of cancer cells with certain genetic dysregulations if you
inhibit the RXL binding pocket of the cyclins.
From the crystal structure of a natural substrate in the RXL binding site of cyclin
A, McInnes and coworkers identified intramolecular
hydrogen bonds between a side chain amide and a backbone amide
that reinforce the active conformation of the substrate,
and they hypothesized that they could emulate this effect by linking that
side chain to the C-terminus of a substrate mimic,
leading them to compound one, which has superior biochemical potency
compared to the equivalent length linear substrate
fragment. But despite that promising initial result,
none of the groups that have worked on this target since have been able to develop
cellularly active inhibitors.
This is because they rely on a conserved charged arginine residue
as a necessary part of the pharmacophore,
so any compound with interesting levels of biochemical activity is not able to
passively permeate a membrane.
Circle Pharma saw this as a perfect opportunity to deploy its discovery
platform to go from this weak biochemical hit with no permeability
to a cellularly potent permeable cyclin inhibitor.
And to enable this, a computational binding model was developed in which
three key interactions were identified, which were to be retained and
optimized throughout the discovery campaign.One,
a central beta strand forms a hydrogen bonding network with the protein target.
Two, there are two lipophilic residues in the macrocycle which settle
into a deep hydrophobic patch.
And three, a beta turn near the N-terminus of the tail
settles into a shallow secondary pocket.
So we begin with this literature compound with absolutely abysmal properties,
and although we do have measurable biochemical activity in our fluorescence
polarization assay for cyclin A,
the MDCK permeability is below the limit of quantitation.
Through an iterative process of computationally driven designs and solid phase
peptide synthesis, the first compound in the history of this target
was identified that has confirmed anti-proliferative cellular
activity against a small cell lung cancer line that has the
exact kinds of genetic dysregulations that were predicted in Bill Kaelin's original
hypothesis.
Building on this momentum, we introduced turn-inducing motifs into both the
macrocycle and into the peptide tail to reinforce the active
conformation of the substrate. And when combined with optimized
hydrophobic contacts, as well as just generally pumping up the lipophilicity of
the molecule,
we arrive at compound three, which has double-digit nanomolar cellular potency
and significantly improved MDCK.
And we were excited enough about this compound that we wanted to profile it
further.
And as you can see, we have come a long way from our literature starting point.
We have single-digit nanomolar biophysical affinity for cyclins A
and B with selectivity over cyclin E, and we will return to
the subject of the different cyclins later.
But this leads to potent inhibition of small cell lung cancer lines with no
effect on healthy human fibroblasts.
Our properties and our in vitro DMPK are maybe not quite where we want them just
yet, but we're at least within striking distance of something a little bit more
drug-like.
And we were delighted to see that when we put this compound into a
CDX mouse model of small cell lung cancer,
we achieved tumor regression at 100 mgs per kg QD via
intraperitoneal dosing with no body weight loss.
So,
huge milestone for us. We have connected the in vitro mechanism of action to
an in vivo phenotypic response.
This hit-to-lead campaign was published in the "Journal of Medicinal Chemistry" so
please go give that a read if you'd like to learn more about this arm of the
program.
That said, as big of an achievement as this was, the compound does not
have oral bioavailability, which we need to advance this compound into the
clinic. So we still have some work to do.
Our primary strategy for optimizing compound three was to reduce its peptidic
character.
We see that by methylating the lariat amide leading up to the bridging
residue, along with a couple of other minor structural modifications, leads
us to compound four, which is equipotent in cellular assay but has
modestly improved MDCK.
By itself, nothing to write home about, but we thought to ourselves, what if
we took this modification even further?
What if instead of just methylating that amide, we get rid of it altogether and
replace the bridging residue with an alkyl chain in a new scaffold
that we dub our long lariat series.
In this particular example, compound five, we have also methylated the long lariat,
and that leads us to a compound with improved cellular activity and further
improved MDCK.
So we think we're onto something at this stage, but our other in
vitro DMPK parameters are still not quite where we want them.
Our solubility is very low, and our plasma protein binding is very
high, which is going to lead to very low free drug fractions in
vivo, which is going to prevent us from seeing efficacy.
But by systematically modifying the phenylalanine residue, we arrive at
compound six, and now we've really gotten somewhere.
Cellular activity and MDCK have once again been improved, and
now our Ksol and our plasma protein binding are in a range where we
feel comfortable advancing this compound into further evaluations in
preparation for a potential in vivo PO efficacy study.
Compound six has low single-digit nanomolar biophysical affinity for
cyclins A and B with moderate selectivity against cyclin E,
and this leads to potent inhibition in multiple small cell lung cancer
lines with no effect, once again, on healthy human fibroblasts.
Properties in in vitro DMPK have been further improved.
In vivo, we see dose proportionality going from 30 to 100
mgs per kg PO in the mouse, and that's hovering at around 30%
F.
And although I'm not showing it today, we have clean profiles across a number of in
vitro safety pharmacology panels.
All of this supports the nomination of compound six to PO oral
efficacy.
So we put this compound into two CDX mouse models of small cell lung
cancer. I will not belabor the details here.
I'm just going to give you the two key takeaways.
One, compound is well-tolerated, as seen in the central body weight
curves.
And two, as we begin to dose up the compound in the mouse,
we start to see robust tumor regressions at the dosing levels, which can
achieve a free Cmax in excess of the GI50, which
is what you're seeing on the right.
And this reinforces the importance of keeping a close eye on that plasma protein
binding and using in vivo free drug fraction as a driving force
for optimization.
We see similar results in patient-derived xenograft models of triple-negative
breast cancer.
This lead optimization portion of the program was also published in "J Med Chem,"
so go give that a read. And although this molecule was not selected
to advance into the clinic, it was an important tool
compound and the marquee molecule of a publication that we put into
"Nature."Detailing the underlying mechanistic
biology of how neither cyclin A inhibition alone nor cyclin
B inhibition alone is sufficient to drive apoptosis.
You really do need to have both.
We also looked at why certain types of cancer cells were susceptible to our
mechanism over others.
As a part of that publication, we put together this little video, and I would like
to show it to you right now.
Cercul Pharma is developing CID078, a
first-in-class macrocyclic cyclin inhibitor designed to disrupt
the cell cycle of malignant cells that have aberrant E2F activity.
CID078 binds to a previously undruggable
hydrophobic patch on each of the cyclin A CDK2 and
cyclin B CDK1 complexes, influencing interactions with
substrates and regulators while sparing the kinase binding site.
Normally, the cyclin A CDK2 complex regulates proper
completion of the S phase of the cell cycle by inactivating
E2F.
In tumor cells with aberrant E2F activity,
CID078 prevents this complex from turning E2F
off, leading to DNA damage and replication stress.
Subsequently, during the G2 and M phases of the cell cycle,
CID078 also disrupts cyclin B
downregulation by MYT1, resulting in sustained
activity of the cyclin B CDK1 complex, forcing the
tumor cells into mitotic division.
These two effects, replication stress with DNA damage and forced
transition into the division phase, combine to produce mitotic catastrophe
and apoptosis, resulting in the death of the tumor cells.
So if you'd like to learn more about that biology, please go give that paper a read
and check out our talks tomorrow and the day after.
There's some really fascinating underlying mechanistic biology behind this
compound.
With the remainder of my time, I would like to tell you about Cercul's second
development program, which was born out of our deep knowledge of cyclin
biology, and that one is focused on cyclin D1.
This particular cyclin mediates progression through the G1 phase of the cell
cycle by pairing with either CDK4 or
CDK6 to phosphorylate the retinoblastoma or
Rb protein.
Cyclin D1 dysregulation is a hallmark of many cancer subtypes, including
heme and ER positive breast malignancies.
I mentioned earlier that resistance development to CDK inhibitors is a
known concern.
Well, it turns out that cyclin D1 amplification is implicated in
lower progression-free survival in patients taking the clinically
approved CDK4/6 inhibitor palbociclib.
So all of this comes together to paint a clear picture of a clinical need, and
Cercul Pharma has rushed in to fill that need with a novel family of
isoform selective cyclin D1 inhibitors, which are orally bioavailable.
We've advanced compounds into preclinical evaluation in preparation to enter the
clinic, and we are expecting an IND filing by the end of the calendar year.
But why are we so interested in isoform selectivity in the first place?
Well, different cell types utilize different isoforms of cyclin
D to drive G1 progression.
Inside of ER-positive breast cancer cells, and in fact, many other cancer cell
types, they are primarily relying on cyclin D1 paired with
either CDK4 or CDK6,
whereas in heme stem cells, as well as many other types of healthy human cells,
they are primarily relying on the D3 CDK6 complex.
CDK4/6 inhibitors are incredibly effective at shutting down Rb
phosphorylation inside of the tumor compartment, but they also do so
in the heme stem cells, which leads to dose-limiting on-target
toxicity, primarily in the form of heme adverse events.
Next generation CDK4 selective inhibitors attempt to circumvent this
problem by only shutting down the D1 CDK4
complex.
Indeed, this does lead to lower toxicity, but it also
gives the possibility that upregulated CDK6 can
compensate for the inactivated complex, leading to G1 escape.
Isoform selective cyclin D1 inhibitors offer the potential for the best of both
worlds. If you can totally shut down both pathways of Rb
phosphorylation inside of the tumor compartment, but you leave the heme stem cells
alone, this could give you an improved therapeutic index.
And in fact, in our preclinical in vitro profiling, we
see heme tox profiles that look a lot more like CDK4 selective inhibitors than
they do CDK4/6 inhibitors.
So we can't talk structures today, but I can tell you that we have identified an
advanced compound which is able to potently inhibit the interaction
between cyclin D1 and Rb,
and it does so in both cell free and intracellular reporter assays.
Importantly, in addition to tuning out the activity against cyclins
A, B, and E, we have also shown that the compound does
not inhibit the interaction between cyclin D3 and Rb, and that's
what you're seeing in those graphs on the right.
Even at micromolar concentrations of compound, we do not reach 50%
inhibition, which should lead to the kinds of improved therapeutic indices that I
referred to on the previous slide.
The advanced compound is able to potently inhibit the proliferation of
mantle cell lymphoma and ER
positive breast cancer lines,
which are dysregulated in cyclin D1,
and it does so with similar levels of potency to the clinically approved
CDK4/6 inhibitors as well as next generation CDK4
selectives.
These results are recapitulated in a broad cell line panel with statistical
significance between the inhibition of D1 driven versus D1 independent
lines.And mechanistically, we have confirmed this to occur
through G1 arrest in an EDU incorporation assay of the mantle cell
lymphoma line JEK01.
The advanced compound causes tumor growth inhibition in a mantle cell
lymphoma CDX mouse model, and it does so with superior
levels of activity to the clinically relevant dose of the standard of
care BTK inhibitor, Acalabrutinib.
And we see that it does so with no body weight loss.
In our pharmacodynamic profiling, we see dose-dependent reductions in
phospho-Rb levels, Ki67, and thymidine kinase
activity, indicating that we are very likely on target for cell
cycle inhibition.
And although this compound was not advanced into preclinical evaluation, it was an
important late tool molecule that we used to learn about our mechanism of
action while we waited for better compounds to come down the pike.
In conclusion, Circle Pharma is using its unique capabilities in the
development of orally bioavailable macrocycles, targeting
intracellular protein-protein interactions
to advance a novel family of cyclin RxL inhibitors.
Our clinical asset, the cyclin AB inhibitor known as
CID-078, is targeting dose expansion this year.
Our follow-on program, the isoform selective cyclin D1 inhibitor, is targeting
entry into the clinic sometime early next year.
And although I didn't talk about it, we also have a collaboration with Boehringer
Ingelheim on an undisclosed family of cyclin inhibitors.
And with that, I would like to thank all of the team members, both past and
present, who made this work possible, some of whom are in the audience today.
I would like to thank the organizers for giving me the opportunity to speak with
you, and I would like to thank all of you for your time and attention.
I would be happy to take any questions.
Not
seeing hands.
Yeah, nice talks. This is Timo from Peptilive.
So I have questions about how to differentiate this
oral bioavailable peptide from small molecular
degraders or small molecular inhibitors.
So don't get me wrong, so I'm also working for a peptide company.
We are very like our peptide, just want to know how to differentiate this kind of
modality with small molecular degraders and
inhibitors.
So, degraders are operating by a completely different
mechanism, right? And in fact, there are plenty of groups working on
making
peptides with molecular glue activity or degrader activity.
How to distinguish them, really we're
going after
protein-protein interactions that have been completely
undruggable, right? It's a totally novel mechanism.
Degraders, a lot of very exciting work happening, but at the end of the day,
you're really talking about just finding a protein that you
know is important and just taking it down, right?
This is a
mechanism that leaves the proteins intact,
which has really important implications for tox,
both on and off-target tox.
Yeah, it's
just a different approach.
Thank you.
I'm Bruce Klarman. I'm at Fred Hutch in Seattle.
So there's very few substrates that really exhibit specificity between cyclin E
CDK2 and cyclin A CDK2, and it's much a matter of
timing in the cell cycle and the amount of kinase activity.
So I'm wondering if you can comment, you mentioned that there's less affinity for
cyclin E, they recognize things rather similarly.
What the basis for the distinction between cyclin E and cyclin A is,
and how that accounts for any of the phenotypes in what you're seeing?
It was a little difficult for me to hear, but what I think you were asking is
about the
importance of the selectivity for cyclins A and B as opposed to cyclin E?
I guess I'm trying to understand that since the substrate specificity of
EK2 and AK2 are so similar, they really differ in the
timing of when they're expressed and the amount of activity they have.
But what's the structural basis for the selectivity that
excludes cyclin E in what you've shown today?
Ah.
Yeah, we don't have any images of crystal structures up here,
but we've got crystal structures, and we know where the residue differences are.
So the RxL binding sites of cyclins A, B,
E,
frankly, even D, are relatively similar.
So you can zoom in and find these key
places where you can really drive
either binding site affinity or ablation of binding.
So it's like you would look at any other small molecule project.
You look for the minor residue differences, and you try to exploit them.
My question is kind of related to the previous question about
selectivity. So for the case study you shared around the
CCND1 inhibitor, I wonder how's the
profile in terms of binding and efficacy to
CDK4D1 versus 6D1,
and did you have a desired profile, and how did
you balance that?
Because we are binding to cyclin D
directly,
it doesn't particularly matter what its binding partner is.
We have roughly equal potency against
D1, whether it is bound to CDK4 or
CDK6, and we ablate the binding of
retinoblastoma to cyclin D. So between those two
targets, there is no distinction.
The distinction comes from whether you are able to
ablate Rb localization to D1 versus
D3.So,
it's really more about the isoform of cyclin
D rather than the CDK.
Thanks.
If there's no more questions, then let's thank Justin for a great talk and
move to the next one.
Rob will be
doing our next talk on a new target that he'll share with us.
Okay. Thank you very much, Amy. Today I'm going to talk to you
about our project to discover
inhibitors of DHXX8, a DEAH box helicase involved in
mRNA splicing. And we carried out this project
in collaboration with Merck KGaA, Darmstadt, in Germany.
So this is my disclosure information.
So the main things are that part of our research as ICR was funded by Merck
and by CRUK.
So as an outline of the talk, I'll introduce you to the role
of DHXX8 in mRNA splicing and the identification
of DHXX8 as a potential cancer target.
I'll talk about the biophysical fragment screening, which was a particularly
effective hit ID approach for us, and its subsequent structure guided
optimization of the fragments to potent DHXX8 inhibitors.
I'll discuss DHXX8 inhibition in cells and human xenografts showing
anti-cancer activity in vitro and in vivo.
I'll talk a bit about the mode of action of a first-in-class DHXX8 inhibitors,
and I compare them with ATX968, an allosteric
DHXX9 inhibitor. And I'll finish by some summary and learnings.
So what is DHXX8? DHXX8 is an ATP-dependent RNA helicase
involved in mRNA splicing. And this is sort of the
removal of introns from pre-mRNA, and that is carried
out by the spliceosome. The spliceosome is a huge protein
RNA complex that assembles on the pre-mRNA
and undergoes a lot of compositional and conformational
changes to allow the splicing reactions to take place.
And at each conformational changes, there are helicases that
facilitate these. So DHXX8 is...
I don't see the pointer, but
DHXX8
acts late in the splicing cycle, and its main role is to
facilitate the release of mature mRNA from the spliceosome.
It is also essential for proofreading and in ensuring splicing
fidelity. So at ICR, we identified
DHXX8 as the top hit in an sRNA library screen for
potential
druggable ATF1 regulators,
because we have a long-standing interest in targeting ATF1 because of its
role in the oncogenic stress response.
So from this discovery, we also found that
DHXX8 silencing or degradation results in intron retention
in ATF1 pre-mRNA, and this leads to reduced
ATF1 levels. We also discovered that it's both the
DHXX8 ATPase activity and its ability to bind
RNA substrate that are required for correct mRNA
splicing of ATF1, MCL1, and other cancer-associated
transcripts. We further found that DHXX8
sRNA knockdown has a greater impact on cancer survival
compared to normal cells, and this suggests a potential
therapeutic window. So this led us to initiate a
project to discover small molecule DHXX8 inhibitors for the
treatment of MYC-amplified and MCL1 or
ATF1-dependent cancers. And if you want to know more
about our target identification of DHXX8 and the role
of DHXX8 in cancer, please check out our recent
publication led by Paul Clarke in "NAR Cancer"
and the poster that my colleague Paul Clarke will be presenting on
Tuesday at this conference.
So at the time when we
started the project, there was hardly anything known about DHXX8.
There were about four papers in the literature.
So we had to build the DHXX8 drug discovery toolbox completely
from scratch. So what
a little bit more was
known about its functional homolog in yeast,
PFP22. So what we did was we started by
recombinant production of both human DHXX8 and yeast
PFP22, the full-length version and the truncated helicase
domains. With these proteins in hand, we set up a suite of
biophysical assays for fragment screening and hit follow-up.
These include thermal shift assay, surface plasmon resonance, and
ligand-observed NMR approaches.
We also set up a series of biochemical assays for high-throughput
screening and hit follow-up, and these included binding assays targeting
the ATP binding site and the RNA binding site
respectively. We also set up an ATP turnover
assay to monitor ATP hydrolysis of the
enzyme. Using these assays, we carried out an
extensive hit ID campaign, and we carried out HTSs
of both the ICR and the Merck KGaA HTS
libraries. We carried out fragment screening of both our fragment
libraries.
And both these approaches led to
chemical hit matter. But the hit matter that yielded the
most advanced compounds came from ICR and the Merck biophysical
fragment screening. So I'll focus on that in the rest of my
talk.So how did we do that? So
at ICR, we screened our in-house ICR fragment library
of about 2,000 compounds in parallel using thermal shift
assay and SPR.
The hits from that were confirmed in SPR concentration
response experiment, and we further characterized the hits
in ligand observed NMR. So at Merck, we screened a
set of 2,000 diverse fragments, and we used
a little bit different. We screened it with SPR in the presence and in
absence of ADP. We followed up with SPR
concentration response experiment, also in the presence and absence of the
ADP, and we further characterized them in TSA.
So the aim of both these screening campaign was to ultimately
characterize the binding mode of the hits in X-ray crystallography,
and on each
screen, we could do that for two hits.
However, for that, you need a crystal structure, and at the start of this
project, no structure of human DHXX8 had been
reported. So at ICR, we determined the structure of
DHXX8 helicase domain in its ADP bound form.
You can see that on your left with ADP binding between the two RecA
domains. And in its
RNA bound form, you can see that in the middle with RNA binding in
the RNA binding tunnel in the middle of the protein.
So what these structures told us was a
lot about the movements that this enzyme goes through when it translocates
RNA, and you can see that from the overlay of the two structures.
The other thing that it did, of course, was it enabled a structure-based drug
design approach, and I'll show you in the next slide how that
worked.
So on the left-hand side, you'd see the very first fragment that we
identified in the ICR fragment screen, and it's a very weak
thermal shift hit. We almost threw this aside because we didn't think
it was real. However, it was
above the statistical cutoff of the screen, so we progressed it to an
SPR experiment, and we could confirm binding.
We then characterized it in our ligand observed NMR approaches,
and in the middle of the slide, you'd see the water loggy
experiment, and in this experiment, the blue spectrum is
the 1D proton NMR spectrum of the compound on its own.
The red spectrum is the compound in the presence of DHXX8
helicase domain, and you could see the change in sign from positive to
negative, which is an indication of binding.
The green spectrum is the compound plus the protein, and also in
the presence of an RNA substrate, and you can see a reduction of the negative
peaks, and that is an indication that the compound is being
competed off. So not only did this experiment confirm again
that this little fragment was binding to it, but it also gave us a first
indication that it was binding in or very close to the RNA binding
tunnel. So solving the structure, the crystal structure of the
fragment bound to DHXX8, in orange, you can
see the little fragment binding in the RNA binding tunnel on the
RecA1 side of the protein. Looking at the close-up
of the binding in the top right-hand
corner, you can see that the fragment binds to a
functional loop in the enzyme in yellow, which is the hook turn motif, which
is important for RNA translocation.
You can also see that the carboxylic acid in this fragment makes all the
polar interaction and is a real anchor point of the fragment.
Overlaying this
fragment bound structure with our RNA bound structure, which you see in the bottom
of the slide, you can see that the carboxylic acid mimics a
backbone phosphate moiety of the RNA substrate,
and the ether-linked phenol link sits where a ribose unit
of a nucleotide would bind. So this caused quite some
excitement within our project, and I guess it's fair to say that
the structural confirmation of our compound one kickstarted the
DHXX8 MedChem design program.
And how we developed that, I'll show you in the next slide.
So on the left-hand side, you'd see the fragment again, and at the
structural picture at the bottom, you could see that it's pretty clear how
we needed to develop this fragment.
We should cross
the RNA binding tunnel, and we try to sort of access a
pocket in the winged helix domain, which is indicated by the purple residues,
to grow the fragment out.
And what helped us a lot was compound 24,
which was an analog of this fragment, but also a hit in
the HCS of the ICR library. And the
structure of this compound showed that the pyridine
carboxylate moiety binds exactly the same as in
compound one, but the extended linker positions the phenol
ring right at the entrance of the pocket and the other side of the
RNA binding tunnel. And here we did two things.
One approach was now to actually branch out further and extend
further into the pocket and try to pick up an interaction with a
serine residue at the entrance of the pocket.
The second thing that we wanted to do was actually optimize the
interaction between a histidine residue and an
arginine residue that sandwiched the linker portion of this molecule.
This yielded compound 34 and compound 43, and compound
34 at the top, you can really see that the amino isopropyl
group binds into the pocket in the winged helix domain, and
indeed, the NH picks up an hydrogen bond with the serine residue
at the entrance of the pocket. So
this was a single-digit micromolar compound.
The substitute in the linker also gave a single-digit
micromolar compound, and you can see that it's the S enantiomer of the
compound that binds in thisin the crystal structure.
Now, the next step was combining these two substituents,
and this actually gave us a big increase in potency.
It yielded compound 51, and this was our first
submicromolar inhibitor. That was further developed,
and we maintained potency in compound 53, but now this
compound also was active in an in-cell pull cell target
engagement, cellular target engagement assay.
But this was as far as it went with this compound because we couldn't
optimize this any further, and we were forced back to look at our
screening output.
And this is shown in the next slide. What we selected was two fragments.
The one on the left came from the IShar library, the one on the right
from the Merck fragment library, and the crystal structures at the bottom show
that they bind in a similar way as our fragment that is shown on the
previous slide. But they were a little bit more potent and more ligand
efficient. Now, the molecule on the very left-hand side, you
all know. That's ibuprofen, and that's a drug in its own right, so we
figured this might be a good starting point.
It didn't take
much to actually arrive at the biaryl compound
five,
which is submicromolar, and you can see that we also
borrowed the amino isopropyl group
from the previous series. Using a structure-based drug
design approach, we managed to improve this compound to the
compound on the very right-hand side of your slide, compound
54, and this is a very potent
biochemically DHXX8 inhibitor, but it
now not only is active in an in-cell pull cellular target
engagement assay, but it is also active in an Mcl1 splicing
assay, so it's a splicing inhibitor.
And just to note, this is not published, so please do not post these
results. So this is the profile of our compound 54,
and so there's two things to highlight here.
Despite the fact that it's a carboxylic acid, we can see that it has
a good permeability and low clearance.
And the second thing is that in the low dose PK experiment that you can see on the
right-hand slide, we have about 24 hours
exposure above the
free cell cellular IC50.
So this led us to progress it into a single dose PK/PD
study in mice bearing SUM159
xenografts. And this experiment showed us
that we had moderate modulation of Mcl1 splicing,
with an effect maximal at six hours, and it was a bit reduced at
24 hours. It also showed us that HSF1
splicing is much more robust and stronger than for
Mcl1. We saw an effect already at three hours and
a strong effect at 24 hours.
So this led us to carry out an efficacy study with compound
54, and you can see we did that at three concentration and can
see that the 50 mgx per kg and 30 mgx per kg concentration showed
efficacy, and the 30 mgx per kg showed two
complete tumor regressions in the 30.
But what we could also see is that actually the body weights of the
highest dose were actually more than 10%, and this proved
an early indication of a narrow therapeutic
index, and that ultimately prevented further
progression of this compound series and the project.
So this was a bit disheartening, but what we did obtain on a positive note,
we obtained potent in vitro chemical tools to unravel the
DEAH box RNA helicase and splicing biology.
So in this context, we were interested to
see if we could sort of get some insight into the mode of
action of our RNA competitive DHXX8 inhibitors at the
molecular level. So what I already told you is that these DEAH box
helicases undergo significant conformational changes,
and the RNA binding tunnel changes from an enclosed tunnel in the
ADP bound conformation to a very open RNA
binding groove in the ATP bound conformation.
And you can see some of that in our ADP bound and our RNA
bound structures in the overlay on the left-hand side of the slides.
So
to facilitate this movement, the winged helix domain,
which is sitting in the middle of the protein, acts
as a hinge. And if you look at where our inhibitors bind, this
amino isopropyl group of our extended linker inhibitors
bind exactly in a pocket in the winged helix domain.
And if you look at the
purple structure, which is the RNA bound structure, you see that the
pocket has moved compared to the compound bound structure, and it starts to
clash with the inhibitor. So what we think is happening is that
by binding our inhibitors in this winged helix domain pocket, it
restricts the conformational plasticity of the enzyme and
stabilizes DHXX8 in an inactive ADP bound
conformation. And there's some
sort of thermal shift data that support this on our compounds.
Because if we go for a compound that doesn't have that amino isopropyl
group to the compound that has the amino isopropyl group,
we see an increase in thermal stabilization about
2.4 degrees.So the next thing that we
did was compare our inhibitors with the allosteric
DHXX9 inhibitors from Akcent Therapeutics.
And DHXX9 is a DEXH box helicase that is
not directly involved in splicing but in R-loop biology.
And we became aware of the inhibitor
when a patent from Akcent Therapeutics was published.
What the patent didn't disclose was the binding site of
ATX968 at the time. So what we did,
because we had an interest in this, we tried to
crystallize DHXX9, which is extremely difficult, as Akcent
also found. We
generated more than 100 crystals, which we sent to the synchrotron and
obtained just one low-resolution 3.4 angstrom data set.
A parallel approach using cryo-EM actually
yielded a 2.6 angstrom structure in which we could see
both the inhibitor and ADP from the first set of grids, and you'd
see these structures on the right-hand side of the
slide. They're very similar, and they're also very similar to the Akcent
structures that were published recently.
So all of these structures show that ATX916 binds
just outside the RNA binding tunnel in a pocket formed
by the RecA1 domain and a so-called MTAD domain, which is
present in DHXX9. This MTAD domain is not present
in DHXX8, so it's not a surprise that the
DHXX9 inhibitors are not active against DHXX8.
But what about the DHXX8 inhibitors
that we developed, are these active in
DHXX9? Now, if you look at the structural overlay on the
bottom left, you can see that our
extended linker inhibitors in blue can actually
bind. There is space for them to bind in that, and
the site there is pretty conserved.
However, our DHXX8 inhibitors in the DHXX9 assays
are inactive. So there's some clues
in the SAR around their extended linker compounds that
point to why that is. So as I told you earlier, sort of
optimizing the interaction between the histidine and the arginine
sandwich
that sandwich the linker by rigidifying and substituting the
linker actually gives us an increase in potency and thermal stabilization.
And
so this region is important for the binding of these inhibitors.
And that is further supported by the fact that if we mutate
the arginine and the phenylalanine in yellow on the
slides of the hook-turn motif, then we actually
almost abolish all the binding of our inhibitors.
But this is a pretty conserved motif in DEXH box
helicases. But the histidine on the other side of the sandwich is
not so conserved, and in fact in DHXX9 it is an asparagine
residue, and so what we think is that this asparagine
might not be able to form as an effective sandwich with the
arginine on the other side
as the histidine in DHXX8 does. So this
may affect the binding of that. So this histidine
is potentially a selectivity determinant, and as it's
not conserved in the family, it suggests that
maybe we can, with RNA competitive
DEXH box inhibitors can
obtain selectivity for individual DEXH box helicase
members.
So in summary, I've shown you a first example of a
structure-guided fragment-based inhibitor approach for the
design of
inhibitors for spliceosomal helicases.
I show you the first potent RNA competitive DHXX8
inhibitors in fact, and it's the first inhibitors of
DHXX8. They have nanomolar potency.
They show cellular target engagement and mRNA
splicing modulation of good decay and therapeutic activity in
human xenografts, albeit with a narrow therapeutic index.
I demonstrated that of the structural basis for selectivity for DHXX8
versus DHXX9, and potentially
a wider helicase selectivity. Now, what we think is that
compound 54 gives us a high-quality chemical probe to explore
the biology of human DHXX8. And as RNA
helicases remain challenging to drug targets, maybe
our approach provides a playbook for the discovery of inhibitors of other
RNA helicases.
So this brings me to the acknowledgments. We had a big team on this.
The medicinal chemistry on the ICR side was led by Julian Black and Gerda
Balay. My own team
that was heavily involved in everything from assays,
biophysics, and structural biology.
The biology at ICR was led by Paul Workman and Paul Clark, and
as I told you this was a great collaboration with
Merck KGaA, and the Merck team was led by Christina
Aster as project leader and Alex Azal and Andreas
Blum led the medicinal chemistry, and just to note that
our compound 54 was synthesized by the Merck medicinal chemistry
team.
So our funders, Cancer Research UK, I'd like to acknowledge they
provided a lot of funding for this, and you saw a lot of crystal structures in this
talk. So I'd like to acknowledge all the synchrotrons at which we collected our
data. So this is where I stop. I thank you for your attention, and
I'm happy to answer any questions.
So Rob, really nice talk.
Thank you.
So can you comment on the extent to which you think the narrow
therapeutic window is an off-target effect of the compound or an
on-target effect?
Yeah.
That's a good question. And actually,
that is something we still don't really know.
So,
this was quite a surprise to us because the compound was quite clean
in
safety and against the Eurofins panels, et cetera.
But
what we think, I think there may be an on-target effect on this,
but it is still not clear. The tox that we saw in the
gut,
for some time, because these inhibitors
were derived from ibuprofen, essentially, we were thinking it might be COX
inhibition. We followed that for a long time, and some
of the metabolites turned out to be weak COX inhibitors,
but they were never at
a concentration that could actually cause quite a
severe gut toxicity. So we're still in Paul Clarke's
team,
at ICR. We're still working to understand if
actually
this is a
particularly unfortunate off-target effect,
whether it's on target, which there might be an on-target
component to it, or
if it is a splicing on mechanism
effect.
Okay. Thank you.
So we'll report on that in the literature, hopefully.
I have a question. You have a really nice understanding of the structure.
Yeah.
And are you looking at other helicases in this
DHX family?
Yes.
And
what we did was we recombinantly produced several of them, and
in some cases, we did actually go to structure determination.
Some we could reproduce from the literature,
but DHX8 itself, no.
Great.
It helped us greatly in actually develop the inhibitors.
It was absolutely crucial because I think it's not
easy still to
develop a fragment to a potent inhibitor without structural data.
Yeah. That's great.
Okay. If no further questions, let's thank Rob.
We're
going to move on to the last speaker, who's me.
So we heard some wonderful talks from both Rob and Justin
on
a new modality as well as a new target, and I'm going to round out the
session with a new mechanism on drugging
oncogenic pathways.
Let's see
if this works.
Okay.
Yeah. So I'm really excited to tell you about my work at Delphia Therapeutics
in activation lethality, where we're working on a new therapeutic
strategy towards drugging these oncogenic signaling pathways.
Really starting with the problem statement of patients are in need of new
therapeutic approaches in oncology.
We see that resistance is responsible for 80% to 90% of
cancer-related deaths by rendering tumors unresponsive to
therapies. You see a patient here who is treated with
a TKI. You get tumor regression, but
shortly after, you get tumor burden once returning again.
In addition, there are many important cancer-driving targets that
remain challenging to drug.
We see beta-catenin here within the Wnt pathway, and I'll tell you a little bit
about our work in both of these areas exemplified in two
different projects.
So the novel strategies in drug discovery are needed to change the treatment
landscape for patients, and there's a huge opportunity for us as drug hunters
and a real responsibility
that we have to make a difference for patients.
Targeted therapy addresses select aspects of these therapeutic
challenges to bring the patient benefit.
We have molecular profiling, which can treat
molecular-defined subsets and brings patient benefit.
However, there are still limitations.
Only 10% of patients benefit to date, and
there's rapid emergence of drug resistance.
So again, next-generation approaches are needed to address these larger
populations and improve upon the resistance.
If we go back to really elemental understanding of
cancer and oncology, we know that cancer is driven by Darwinian
evolution. And selective pressures on
mutant cells during tumor formation and progression is what's driving
this oncology
signaling.
We pay a lot of attention to the positive regulators, which is
driving this progression, and we aim to inhibit it.
But what about the negative nodes, and how could we learn from those
and potentially target those specific nodes,
targeting the events that are selected against?
And as we look further in the cancer genetics, it reveals mutual
exclusivity, and
that cancers can't tolerate this overactivation.
So targeting these negative nodes could actually be a huge benefit.
On the left here, you'll see that, using MAPK as an
example,
mutations are mutually exclusive in human non-small cell lung
cancer, showing that if you look at KRAS and EGFR
mutations, they never overlapAnd so they
are mutually exclusive. In addition, on the right-hand side, you
see
when one tries to make a tumor that is doubly mutant for
EGFR and KRAS, our expected result is that we may have a
super tumor. However, our actual result is that you get no
double mutant EGFR, KRAS tumors. So this
novel class of cancer genetics leads to a paradoxical finding,
that cancers can't tolerate too much oncogenic activity.
And therefore, how do we, as drug hunters, take advantage of this?
So our model of activation lethality is actually quite simple in
what you can see here. When you have no mutations, you have a normal
cell. When you have mutation A, you drive cancer.
When you have mutation B, you drive cancer.
However, when you have mutation A and B, the cell can't tolerate it,
and you therefore get cell death.
So really what we like to focus on is really
looking at the patient and the disease.
Bill Sellers actually did a
really nice study where he looked at almost 70,000 tumor
samples across 11 indications. And they put those through
a novel computational pipeline and looked
at pairwise mutually exclusive assessment across oncogenes.
And what he found is that
this validates MAPK in a variety of indications.
You don't see any double mutations here.
And you can see that all in the red there across different diseases.
It also identified multiple additional mutually exclusive
oncogenes,
including prevalent mutations in the PI3K, which is in
green, and the WNT, which is in blue.
So this highlights the real huge opportunity we have here to
look at targeting these different pathways in these different
diseases for patients.
So now that we see that there's lots of opportunity in terms of the
pathways, the patient populations, we want to think about how we could
potentially drug these particular pathways.
And there's two approaches that we're taking.
One is to break the brake, and the other is allosteric activation.
Breaking the brake is essentially removing or blocking our
negative regulators of the pathway, thereby driving
activation. With the allosteric activators, it's simple.
It's not simple, but it's similar to a allosteric
inhibitor where we're binding to a site outside of the active site and
driving activation or activity of that particular target.
So taking these two things together in terms
of understanding the pathways and the pathways that
are sensitive to this type of mutual exclusivity
and the negative nodes, in addition to understanding the drug ability of the
pathway, we saw that several nodes of the MAPK pathway are
drugable and can be considered for activation.
So I don't need to explain to this group how important the MAPK pathway
is and how many nodes that many of us have actually worked on and
conquered in terms of making inhibitors.
And now how can we couple that with our
efforts towards making an activator?
So what we found, what we started to look at was, what are the MAPK
negative regulators?
And we found that
MAPK negative regulators are selectively essential in many MAPK
mutant cancers. You'll see here that what we found
through our analysis is that ERK, MEK,
p15, and DUSP are all essential here, which is likely no
surprise. And coupling that learning with understanding the
structure of the ERK-p15 complex,
we decided to go after that particular node of drugging
this particular pathway.
And so what we did was we
did a number of different screens actually, and we were able to discover a
functional disruptor of the ERK p15 interaction, which you see there,
our
hit molecule, DTX-067. We were quickly able
to solve the crystal structure of this particular molecule and saw that it bound
at the interface of where p15, the negative regulator,
interacted with ERK. So we were very excited about this
more advanced hit, and we were able to
use this crystal structure to drive our SAR in medicinal chemistry
to advance the molecule rapidly in
potency and properties. And so you can see here, advancing from
DTX-067 to what we're calling
DTX-MAPK1, we were able to increase the
biochemical potency by 300-fold and the cellular potency
by about 1,000-fold. So this gave us a really
great in vivo molecule to work with.
And in addition to providing a very potent
molecule with good properties, we were also able to see, through
RNA-seq data, that we had
a very selective molecule. So in the upper left-hand side, you
can see that we have
very nice activation
in a WM melanoma cell line with our MAPK1.
However, when you add the inhibitor, dabrafenib, you
silence all of the noise, if you will.
In addition, we saw that MAPK1 has only modest
effects in normal hepatocytes. So this was quite exciting to us and showed
really the potential for the selectivity and potential TI.
When we looked at this particular molecule in vivo, we see a
similar effect in terms of
normal versus tumortissue where we're seeing really
nice PD induction and pERK activation in the tumor
and very little in the skin and liver.
So this larger pathway induction in tumor and versus normal cells
and high selectivity for ERK,
we think may be beneficial with respect to our TI.
In addition, the MAPK activators
display really nice efficacy and
selectivity in terms of wild type versus mutant.
So on the left-hand side, you see there, we have no activity in
the HMCB line, which is in gray, whereas all of the
other cell lines that are mutant, we see really nice activity
there, cytotoxicity. In addition, we see that
MAPK activators versus MAPK inhibitors, we see
very potent
growth inhibition in the MAPK activators and even more so
than what we know and what we see with some of the
best inhibitors out there.
This then translates directly into in vivo, where we're able
to see substantial efficacy in BRAF mutant cancers,
both in the mutant melanoma model and a colorectal model,
where upon single daily dose at 60 mgs per kg,
we're really crushing the tumors, which is quite exciting for us.
And this was our proof of concept internally, that molecules
that prevent this negative regulation and activate the
MAPK pathway are able to drive robust efficacy in vivo at
tolerated doses.
So we were very excited to have this proof of concept
for activation lethality
in-house. And the question comes back to the beginning of
how can this impact resistant populations?
And so
just thinking about where we are today, our growth and
understanding of cancer drivers and diverse drugging modalities
has given us a rich set of oncogene
inhibitors, using KRAS as an example here.
However, a lot of these inhibitors have short-lived benefit due to the
rapid emergence of resistant mutations.
And that's on the right. And you can see it's not just one mutation, it's multiple
mutations. So it's really hard to make a single medicine
towards this,
and highlights the real need, again, for new medicines.
What we were able to find with our MAPK activator is that
introduction of a KRAS, what we did was we
introduced a KRAS inhibitor resistance to
specific cell lines. And we were able to show that
our particular MAPK activators,
these
resistance setting actually was sensitized to our
MAPK activator. So you can see the parental in gray,
whereas the inhibitor
resistant, which are in the colors there, are way shifted
left. So our MAPK activators are much more effective in those
resistant populations. In addition, we also did a study where
we overexpressed
KRAS, and we saw that this is greatly sensitized in a
diverse KRAS mutant cancer to our MAPK
activator. Almost a thousandfold shift in multiple
different cell lines there.
So this is quite exciting for us that
the resistance setting
is actually more sensitive to our MAPK
activator.
All right. And even more exciting here is that we did an additional
study to look at
kind of flipping that on its head and seeing if we could actually
resensitize to a MAPK inhibitor. And so what we did here is we
took a BRAF mutant melanoma model.
We treated with a RAF inhibitor, dabrafenib, until that became
resistant.
And so the gray is the parental model.
The black is the post-resistance to dabrafenib.
And then when we treated with our Delphia MAPK activator until it became
resistant and rechallenged with dabrafenib, you can see it
resensitizes to make the inhibitor active again.
And so that's what you see there in red.
So this is pretty exciting because it makes the inhibitor
actually useful again, and the cell line's
non-resistant. And so our MAPK activator therapy may
actually enable retreatment with the MAPK pathway inhibitors in the
clinic, and you can imagine that being super impactful to patients.
And so this is one of the most exciting pieces of what we're
doing right now,
where in addition to monotherapy efficacy, MAPK
activators actually enhance the treatment effect of oncogene
pathway inhibitors. And we're calling this phenomenon cross-sensitization.
And it really brings two value propositions, where it
brings increased probability of success for our activators, because
likely we'll be going into inhibitor-resistant patients.
But also it brings a potential for us to
hold the tumor in check and
really keeping the tumor down and
keeping those patients hopefully surviving longer.
So
that's
one piece of the story and something we're very, very excited about.
And what we wanted to ask next, and what many of you may be asking is,
does activation lethality extend beyond the MAPK
pathway?And so in addition to
MAPK, you saw early on in the talk that Wnt was another
highlight where we could actually potentially
benefit from hitting negative nodes in the pathway.
And so
many of us know
within the Wnt pathway, this is a very important space
for oncology. And in normal tissues, beta-catenin levels are
kept low by activity of the destruction complex.
So the destruction complex is creating
ubiquitination of beta-catenin, thereby
degrading beta-catenin.
When the Wnt pathway mutations cripple the destruction
complex, this leads to a lack of ubiquitination and degradation
of beta-catenin and an increased level of beta-catenin,
creating a number of different cancers, including
colorectal, uterine, liver, stomach, and melanoma.
And so one of the questions we had is, we know
loss of beta-catenin can prevent growth of APC
mutant CRC. Could gain of beta-catenin prevent growth of APC?
And so there are many nodes within the destruction complex that we could consider.
And we looked at a number of them, and we saw that
by
silencing either beta-catenin, APC,
or CK1 alpha, we are able to increase
the levels of active beta-catenin.
And this increase in levels of active beta-catenin in
APC and CK1 alpha or decrease within knocking
out beta-catenin itself actually leads to similar
levels of decrease in cell viability.
So again, there are multiple nodes of this APC
destruction complex that are offered to us as potential drugging
targets.
As we considered all of these nodes, we decided to go after the
CK1 alpha node, where we could break the brake
of the destruction complex. And
there were multiple reasons for this.
One was APC is a fairly large protein, which is
difficult to work with. Beta-catenin is difficult to
inhibit, as many of us know. And CK1 alpha,
there were many starting points there.
So we started with this particular CK1
alpha degrader chemical starting point, which was
disclosed by Christina Wu back in 2023, and
we started to look at the activity of this particular molecule.
We can see that it's a potent CK1 alpha degrader.
It is increasing active beta-catenin, but at high
doses or high concentrations.
And it does have a slight GSPT1 activity.
So there was room for improvement here.
We were able to drive med chem once
again to lead to a potent molecular glue
degrader of CK1 alpha, and we showed that this
activated the Wnt pathway. So on the upper left, we see,
again,
potent CK1 alpha degradation, and then the beta-catenin
reporter activity where we're seeing activation of that
pathway. And you can see on the right-hand side, this is just
reported in numbers, but we also have
good properties with the exception of solubility, which we were able to address
with a spray dry formulation.
We did a lot of modeling based on the structural understanding of
CK1 alpha and cereblon, and we were able to use that to drive some of
our optimization there. And we also were able to
show that this is a very selective CK1 alpha
degrader through our proteome-wide
selectivity at a high concentration within HT29
cells. So this was, again, very exciting for us.
We showed that this selectively blocked proliferation of APC
mutant CRC
in HT29s and CWA2s, so APC mutant cell
lines
with p53 mutant or p53 wild type
phenotypes.
In RKO, we see very little activity in the APC wild type,
p53 wild type.
We have a strong PK/PD relationship in this
HT29 CDX model where we have
dose-responsive exposure on the left-hand
side, and this leads to potent CK1 alpha
degradation in vivo
and also dose-responsive increase in the Wnt
pathway, which we read out by Axin2 expression.
And this then led to really nice
degradation.
The degradation in vivo led to prevention of growth
of the APC mutant CRC in vivo, both in CDX models
on the left-hand side there in HT29s and also in
PDX models. This is one example of the PDX where we saw
very nice stasis from our molecule dose, 10 mgs per
kg VID.
So
I think in summary, we've shown that activation lethality is a
broad phenomenon where we see it across multiple different
indications and patient populations, as well as in many different
pathways, including MAPK, PI3K,
and Wnt, two of which I exemplified today.
We showed that activation lethality is druggable.
So with Erc, we had a
PPI
disruption of Erc and p15. In CK1 alpha, we went
after a degrader approach. And that's something that we're very
agnostic to, is the type of modality that we're using
to approach this drugging
strategy.In addition, activation lethality
works. We have strong anticancer activity, both in the MAPK
pathway in RAF mutant cancers, as well as in the WNT pathway
in APC mutant cancers. And finally, and one of the things I'm most
excited about is that the activation lethality therapies
have this cross-sensitization phenomenon,
which may partner with oncogene inhibitors.
And so not only be a really, really powerful single
agent for patients, but also recover some of the activity
of the inhibitors and keep the tumors at bay.
And so I want to acknowledge we're a small but mighty team here.
I'm so proud of this team for doing all the work that they
have over the past three years or so.
So very
thankful for this team and all of our valued external partners and team members.
And thank you for listening, and happy to take any questions.
Yep.
Hi, Amy. Great talk.
To what extent are you concerned about oncogenesis in healthy
tissues?
If you think about, say, BRAF inhibition, you get paradoxical
activation, you get these secondary malignancies.
Is this a concern with some of these MAPK activating kind of
modalities?
Yeah. We've looked at a number of different cell lines.
This question comes up a lot.
And we've looked at a number of different cell lines, both in MAPK and
other pathways, and we never see
the growth that I think you're asking about.
And within some of the
in vivo models as well, we don't ever see
an exacerbation or a growth of the tumor.
So right now, we don't have any evidence of that.
And so right now, we're not necessarily concerned. Yep.
Thanks.
Thank you.
So very nice talk. Congratulations for taking on this
very attractive and innovative
approach. And you've clearly exemplified it and shown that you can get the
synthetic lethality in these two pathways.
And the resensitization is really interesting as
well. However, and just for clarity, I don't think it means that you
won't get resistance to your activators, right?
Yes.
That will happen. And of course,
this is not a reason not to do it, right?
Mm-hmm.
To be clear, people shouldn't go away with the notion this is a new approach where
resistance will be overcome. You'll overcome previous
resistance. But it'd be interesting to see how rapidly you see
resistance to the
new modality itself. So I wondered if you started looking at that-
Yes
... and whether you indeed see resistance and-
Yep
... standard by structure.
Again, great question. Yes, we have.
And so,
you're right. We have shown that we do get
resistance when we treat with our activator.
We are able to combat that resistance.
We have shown,
one of the slides, maybe I didn't point it out well enough, but
we can get resistance to our activator, and we've shown this in cells.
We haven't shown this in vivo. But then when you treat with
your inhibitor, you actually resensitize to the inhibitor.
So it's
a really nice attribute in terms of, yes, we will get
resistance, and I think that's something I think we're aware
of and watching. What we hope and what we're
seeing, at least preliminarily in cells, is that we're able
to combat that activator resistance with
resensitizing to our inhibitor.
Thank you.
Yep.
Really nice talk.
Thanks.
I'm wondering to what degree this is all applicable to loss of function
mutation. We mostly saw cases of gain of function,
oncogenic drivers. But if you have pathway dependency
due to loss of function, is this still an applicable approach?
Yeah. That's a good point. We haven't quite looked at
that yet. But something we should definitely think
about more. Yeah.
Hi, Amy. Beautiful talk. I was curious, so with a lot of the
orthosteric ERK binders, you get this buildup of
phospho-ERK that's sort of there, but inhibited.
And so for your p15 site binders, do you see something similar?
So presumably, your PD marker is phospho-ERK elevation.
Mm-hmm.
Do you have a sense for whether a certain pool of that remains sort of
bound and inhibited, though present?
So you're asking, are we building
up?
Because you're building up phospho-ERK inhibited by your p15 binder,
kind of similar to what we see-
Mm
... with the orthosteric ERK binder.
Yeah. So
hopefully I'm answering your question.
We bind phospho-ERK.
We have more selectivity towards phospho-ERK than
non-phosphorylated ERK. So
ideally, we're kind of driving that
or holding that in check, I think this is what you're asking, I'm not sure, and
building that up. Is that-
You want to do the opposite, though. You want it to be elevated, right?
Yes.
The phospho-ERK. Okay. I was just curious if the phospho-ERK that you have is
inactive
or-
Is it already at a high level?
I
guess I'm not fully understanding.
I'm sorry.
Yeah. Literally. But just because you typically get these big pools of
phospho-ERK, and that's what you want,
in the orthosteric case,
it's a high pool, but it's inactive because it's bound by the
inhibitor.And so I just was-
Oh, is that enough? Yeah
... I was curious if you see the same thing with the-
Yeah. We haven't seen it yet, so
yeah, not quite.
Okay. Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi there. I agree, a really excellent talk and really interesting
concept. I just wanted to follow up on Paul's previous question about
resistance.
So you might imagine that one way you might generate resistance
is, for example, um, upregulation of basic keratin or,
for example,
loss or regulation of your BRAC, right?
Just-
Yep
... transcriptionally, and that could be quite fast, and I just wondered
how fast you're seeing resistance emerging.
How fast we're seeing resistance emerging?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think in the cell, it takes quite a long time.
We don't know how that will translate in vivo.
I'm assuming it might be even longer.
So we'll have to see how that plays out
exactly. But I do think it's going to be really important to
do those studies and really understand that better to really
capitalize on the full potential of what we're trying to accomplish with this.
Yeah.
Thank you. I always love when I get to learn a new concept at
ACR, and this was pretty cool.
With regards to the MAP kinase pathway and the resistance, similar
questions along the lines that have come up,
have you thought about how you might, instead of treating for resistance and then
you've made them more sensitive and then go back to the other drug, is some kind of
more informed intelligent
sequencing? And I don't know how quickly that would be.
One week you give the activator, one week you give the inhibitor, or three weeks
on.
There might be a way to kill more cells in ways of resistance.
Yes. Yeah. 100%. So that's something we
definitely want to explore a bit more, and we haven't quite gotten there.
But yeah, the schedule of how we actually
get the best benefit out of this cross-sensitization and this
cyclical therapy, we still have to understand whether it's, like you
said, one month off, one month on, one week off, one week on,
to really drive down that cancer. We still
have a lot of work to do there. But thank you.
All right. Thank you for all the questions, and thank you for the
speakers for this session. And thank you all for listening and
being engaged. And we'll conclude the session there.